bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat le projet de loi sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi fait son retour
cet après midi dans l'hémicycle du sénat
pour un dernier vote avant sans
l'adoption définitive par le parlement
je vous rappelle que ce texte transcrit
dans la loi l'accord signé le 11 janvier
dernier entre le patronat et trois
syndicats
il crée à la fois plus de flexibilité
pour les entreprises tout en créant de
nouveaux droits pour les salariés au
sénat l'examen de ce texte en séance
publique avait été particulièrement
houleux il faut dire que le gouvernement
avait eu recours à la procédure dite du
vote bloqué pour accélérer les débats
mécontent de l'utilisation de cette
procédure la droite sénatoriale mais
aussi les sénateurs écologistes et
communistes ont donc fait pression sur
le gouvernement pour retarder l'adoption
définitive de ce texte
cet après midi à la séance devrait
néanmoins être beaucoup plus calme alors
tout de suite sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle pour suivre cette séance bon
après midi à tous pour la parole est à
madame eliane assassi eliane assassi
merci monsieur le président ce rappel au
règlement se font sur l'a36 donc
monsieur le président monsieur premiers
messieurs le ministre mes chers
collègues le débat démocratique n'a pas
eu lieu au parlement sur ce projet de
loi dit de sécurisation de l'emploi qui
est au contraire un projet de loi de
fragilisation des droits des salariés
dans l'entreprise
le débat démocratique n'a pas eu lieu
pour trois raisons principales
d'emblée le texte soumis aux
parlementaires a été à prendre ou à
laisser
l'accord passé entre certains
partenaires sociaux je rappelle ici que
la première et la troisième
confédérations syndicales n'ont pas
signé ce texte c'est à coire devait donc
d'emblée s'imposer à la représentation
nationale comme l'a explicitement
exprimé le président de la république
lui-même ainsi que madame parisot
présidente du medef est ainsi que vous
l'avez indiqué vous même monsieur le
ministre
une telle démarche contraire à
esprit et à la lettre de la constitution
qui pose dès la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen qu'une partie
de la nation si importante soit elle ne
peut imposer ses vues à l'ensemble de la
nation que les parlementaires au
vocation à représenter dans leur
ensemble la voie choisie celle d'imposer
un accord très loin de faire l'unanimité
dangereuse pour l'avenir de la
démocratie parlementaire les assemblées
après avoir été dessaisie du pouvoir
budgétaire confiée aux libéraux
européens vont elles être à l'avenir des
saisies de la politique sociale monsieur
mini cette question n'est pas un débat
doctrinal de salon c'est une question
politique fondamentale cette volonté
d'imposer au parlement un accord social
s'est soldée par un échec
seule une majorité relative de députés
puis de sénateurs à voter ce texte et
seule la bienveillance de la droite a
permis son adoption
deuxième point le gouvernement a opté
pour la procédure accélérée qui limite à
une lecture par assemblée l'examen du
texte
l'importance la technicité de ce texte
aurait justifié que cette pause ils
procédure que toute la gauche dénonce et
sous nicolas sarkozy ne soit pas utilisé
son utilisation est d'autant plus
regrettable que l'article 44-3 a été
mise en oeuvre par le gouvernement
constituant le troisième point
d'atteinte au débat démocratique sur ce
texte en effet le vote bloqué à couper
court au débat au sénat
de fait la combinaison de vote bloqué
hélas procès de la procédure accélérée
prive de tout débat réel sur l'ensemble
du texte par le sénat
cette combinaison de deux procédures
entraîne selon nous une violation de la
constitution
cette remarque nous apparaît d'autant
plus fondée que le vote bloqué a été
dégainée par vous même monsieur le
ministre
après moins de 48 heures de débat sur
les articles du projet de loi
faut-il rappeler que lionel jospin
n'avait jamais utilisé une telle
procédure
même à l'encontre de l'opposition et que
françois fillon l'a utilisé sur les
retraites
au bout de trois semaines de discussions
de toute évidence
monsieur le ministre vous n'avez pas
supporter le travail précis opiniâtre de
notre groupe mais aussi d'autres
sénateurs de la majorité qui au delà des
généralités
permettez point par point de mettre en
évidence la nocivité du projet de loi
pour les salariés il faut le reconnaître
le gouvernement n'avait pas prévu le
délai nécessaire pour débattre de ce
projet de loi
alors qu'un débat sérieux s'annonçait le
respect du droit constitutionnel
d'amendements exiger de prendre le temps
le gouvernement ne voulait pas de ce
débat et il a imposé le silence un
groupe de la majorité sénatoriale
dès le début de la discussion
parlementaire c'est un acte grave je
voulais déjà dit monsieur le ministre il
ne restera pas sans conséquences
monsieur le président cette violence
insupportable fait au parlement fait au
sénat ne peut rester sans suite
une réflexion doit s'engager au plus
vite pour redonner au parlement le
pouvoir qui devait s il devrait être le
sien dans un régime démocratique
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de la majorité
nous avons combattu ensemble le mépris
dont fut victime le parlement sous
l'hyperprésidence de nicolas sarkozy
comment concevoir que le changement
annoncé se solde par l'acceptation de la
toute puissance de l'exécutif face à un
parlement toujours plus amoindrie les
sénatrices et les sénateurs du groupe
crc continueront à faire valoir malgré
cette méthode brutale qu'une autre
politique est possible à gauche et que
le libéralisme qui fondent ce projet de
loi n'est pas un horizon indépassable
merci madame la présidente acté données
de votre déclaration la parole est à
monsieur pierre charon
merci monsieur le président je demande
la parole pour un rappel au règlement
dans la nuit du 13 au 14 mai de graves
incidents ont entaché la fête que paris
attendait depuis 19 ans grâce à la
victoire du psg
ces débordements ultra violents n'ont
pas su être anticipé ni même gérer alors
qu'une mise à sac des champs elysées
avaient déjà eu lieu la veille
cette gestion calamiteuse des violences
qui ont déferlé sur la capitale n'est
malheureusement pas sans rappeler
l'incompétence dont on avait déjà fait
preuve le préfet de police bernard
boucault à l'occasion d'une
manifestation familiale et non violente
contre le mariage pour tous certains
élus socialistes ont osé parler de
récupération
devant les réactions d'élus parisiens je
les invite à les expliquer leur vision
des choses aux touristes dont l'autocar
a été pris d'assaut comme une diligence
je les invite à l'expliquer aux
commerçants qui ont été attaqués pillés
menacé et dont les magasins ont été
saccagés qu'il ne faut pas en faire une
histoire la presse internationale
regarde interloquée
le spectacle de la violence qui déferle
sur paris je demande donc au ministre de
l'intérieur manuel valls de prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent pour que les
futures manifestations notamment celle
du 26 mai soit gérée par un préfet de
police professionnelle et pas en
préretraite
soucieux du respect du droit de
manifester et de la sécurité des
parisiens
merci mon cher collègue tact et données
de votre déclaration
mes chers collègues j'ai le regret de
vous faire part du décès de notre ancien
collègue jean david qui feu sénateur de
l'aube de 1978 à 1981 par courrier en
date du 6 mai 2013 monsieur le premier
ministre a fait part de sa décision de
placer en application de l'article l eau
2 197 du code électoral monsieur ronan
dantec sénateur de loire atlantique et
monsieur michel delebarre sénateur du
nord
en mission temporaire auprès de monsieur
pascal canfin ministre chargé du
développement
cette mission portera sur la
contribution des collectivités
territoriales à la préparation des
négociations sur le changement
climatique acte est donnée de cette
communication
en application de l'article 45 alinéa 2
de la constitution le gouvernement
engagé la procédure accélérée pour
l'examen du projet de loi habilitant le
gouvernement à légiférer pour accélérer
les projets de construction et du projet
de loi habilitant le gouvernement à
simplifier les relations entre
l'administration et les citoyens déposé
sur le bureau de l'assemblée nationale 2
mai 2013 et du projet de loi organique
relatif au procureur de la république
financiers déposés sur le bureau de
l'assemblée nationale le 7 mai 2013
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi relatif à la
sécurisation de l'emploi dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur claude jeannerot rapporteur
pour le sénat de la commission mixte
paritaire
vous avez la parole monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues nous voici donc parvenu
au terme de l'examen du projet de loi
relatif à la sécurisation de l'emploi
qui a été déposée au début du mois de
mars sur le bureau de l'assemblée
nationale
comme vous le savez ce texte dense et
techniques et vous avez pu le mesurer
tout au long de ces travaux ce texte a
sur la transcription fidèle mais
enrichie de vos contributions
j'y reviendrai des stipulations de
l'accord national interprofessionnel du
11 janvier dernier
signé par trois organisations
représentatives des salariés et par
l'ensemble des organisations
représentatives des employeurs
ce texte porte trois objectifs
principaux
tout d'abord créer des droits
individuels et collectifs nouveau pour
les salariés ensuite lutter contre la
précarité du travail
enfin anticiper et accompagner les
mutations économiques
sur le fond il a l'ambition de
promouvoir un nouveau modèle économique
et social
sa vocation est de changer radicalement
notre approche des questions économiques
et sociales
car il n'oppose plus d'un côté
compétitivité des entreprises et de
l'autre sécurisation des parcours
professionnels l'emploi occupe désormais
la place centrale vers laquelle
convergent les intérêts des entreprises
et des salariés afin de combattre le
fléau du chômage
l'examen du projet de loi à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat n'a pas dénaturé
l'accord des partenaires sociaux
c'était notre volonté majoritaire
le parlement a veillé à conserver
l'équilibré général du projet de loi
tout en y apportant certaines
clarifications afin de le rendre plus
lisible et de le sécuriser juridiquement
en d'autres termes j'ai le sentiment et
je le dis avec toute la modestie qui
sied à ce type de sujet j'ai le
sentiment que nous avons su conjuguer le
temps de la démocratie sociale et celui
de la démocratie parlementaire
l'exercice a parfois été difficile
il est sans doute perfectible mais le
parlement me semble-t-il à d'ores et
déjà donné la preuve qu'il était
possible de légiférer autrement dans
notre pays en matière sociale alors même
que le gouvernement a déposé le 13 mars
dernier un projet de loi constitue chers
collègues
alors même que le gouvernement a déposé
le 13 mars dernier un projet de loi
constitutionnelle visant à inscrire le
dialogue social préalable dans la
constitution
nous avons montré aux partenaires
sociaux
mais je vous en laisse seuls juges chers
collègues que nous étions capables de
respecter le résultat de leurs
négociations tout en conservant nos
prérogatives de législateurs une
nouvelle époque pour le dialogue social
me semble-t-il vient de s'ouvrir avec
l'examen de ce texte nous en sommes tous
conscients et je suis sûr que nous en
mesurons bientôt les conséquences
heureuses
j'ai pour ma part la conviction que la
deuxième conférence sociale qui
s'ouvrira le 20 juin prochain dressera
un bilan positif de la première feuille
de route sociale et confortera le
renouveau du dialogue social dans notre
pays
je ne souhaite pas revenir sur les
apports des deux assemblées en cours de
navettes préférant si vous le voulez
bien me concentrer sur les conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire qui
s'est réuni mardi 23 avril et qui ont
été adoptées par l'assemblée nationale
dès le lendemain nous sommes parvenus
avec nos collègues députés à des
positions communes prenant en compte
tout à la fois les avancées réalisées au
sénat et à l'assemblée nationale sur les
quelques sujets qui restaient encore en
discussion naturellement la commission a
longuement examiné l'article 1er qui
constitue une avancée essentielle car
ils organisent je le rappelle la
généralisation des complémentaires santé
collective dans toutes les entreprises
mais c'est lui aussi qui a fait débat
sur ces nombreux vents sur de nombreux
bancs de cette assemblée
la cmp vous le savez a rétabli la
possibilité pour les partenaires sociaux
de désigner au niveau de la branche un
ou des assureurs
que ce soit pour la prévoyance ou la
santé
je veux être explicite une fois encore
nous avons entendu par là même laissé
toute liberté aux partenaires sociaux de
la branche pour déterminer pour
déterminer par dont les modalités de
gestion de ces couvertures au bénéfice
des salariés désignation recommandations
ou libre choix des entreprises par une
mise en concurrence transparentes et
équitables entre les candidats la loi
fixe un cadre prudentiel exigeante pour
prévenir les conflits d'intérêts les
prestataires non retenus pourront
d'ailleurs je le précise grâce aux
dispositions que nous adoptons se
tourner vers la justice pour contester
une désignation ou une recommandation
qui ne seraient pas conformes selon eux
aux conditions prévues par la loi
interdire la possibilité de désigner un
seul assureur aurait réduit sensiblement
je le crois l'intérêt de la
mutualisation qui est pourtant essentiel
pour les salariés les moins bien
couverts et pour les petites entreprises
cette interdiction est également
déstabiliser le fonctionnement des
régimes professionnels de prévoyance qui
sont aujourd'hui désigné par la branche
je pense par exemple au secteur du
bâtiment
enfin la mutualisation je dis bien la
mutualisation au niveau de la branche
est la seule mes chers collègues à même
de pouvoir financer la portabilité des
droits pour les chômeurs et les droits
non contributifs que nous organisons
notamment le maintien des garanties en
cas de non paiement des cotisations par
l'entreprise mais comme le disait
justement notre collègue jean marie
vanlerenberghe l'arbre ne doit pas
cacher la forêt je souhaite donc
maintenant évoquer les autres articles
du texte compte personnel de formation
conseil en évolution professionnelle
mobilité volontaire sécurisé voilà trois
outils de sécurisation des parcours
professionnels qui constituent autant
d'avancé décisif pour les salariés
l'article 4 qui réforment et enrichit
les consultation des institutions
représentatives du personnel a été
rétabli et intègre les modifications que
je souhaitais y apporter en séance
publique au sénat
ainsi la nouvelle base de données
économiques et sociales sera également
accessible aux membres du comité
d'hygiène de sécurité et de conditions
de travail
quant à l'article 5 qui ouvre les
conseils d'administration des grandes
entreprises aux représentants des
salariés
je vous rappelle qu'il avait été très
largement réécrit à l'initiative de
notre collègue gaétan gorce rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des lois
il avait en particulier simplifier sa
structure dans un souci de fidélité à
l'accord national interprofessionnel
le texte de la cmp est très largement
conforme à ses acquis tout en accélérant
sa mise en oeuvre
l'article 8 sur le temps partiel a été
une nouvelle fois particulièrement
débattu en cmp j'estime qu'il va
permettre une réelle amélioration de la
situation des salariés à temps partiel
surtout il ne me semble pas nécessaire
d'introduire de nous
dérogation au plancher minimum
hebdomadaire de 24 heures au contraire
c'est par le dialogue social que les
branches doivent être capables d'adapter
ses dispositions à leurs contraintes
propres comme vous l'avez souvent
rappelé monsieur le ministre la
commission mixte paritaire a également
réparé un oubli du projet de loi à
l'article 12 qui n'évoquait pas les
indemnités contractuelles de préavis et
de licenciement en cas de rupture du
contrat de travail d'un salarié dans le
cadre d'un math d'un accord de maintien
de l'emploi
désormais le calcul de ces indemnités
contractuelles sera aligné sur le régime
des indemnités légales et
conventionnelles
un mot enfin si vous le permettez sur
les conseils des prud'hommes qui ont
animé nos discussions en cmp monsieur le
ministre nous prenons très à coeur
las condes la question des conditions de
fonctionnement de la justice prud'homale
compte tenu de l'importance qu'elle
revêt auprès de nos concitoyens et
compte tenu aussi des difficultés
rencontrées par les juges pour remplir
leur office
c'est pourquoi notre commission des
affaires sociales a adopté un amendement
présenté par le groupe crc visant à
demander au gouvernement un rapport au
parlement sur les conditions d'accès à
la justice prud'homale dans les six mois
suivant la promulgation de la loi nous
serons par conséquent très vigilant sur
le respect du délai imposé au
gouvernement pour rendre ce rapport et
sur ses propositions
d'autant que le conseil supérieur de la
prud'homie devrait rendre ses propres
recommandations avant le premier
semestre 2013
mes chers collègues ce projet de loi qui
procède du dialogue social au niveau
national et interprofessionnel renvoie
comme vous le savez
à de nombreuses concertations et
négociations pour préciser certaines de
ses dispositions
je pense notamment à la concertation qui
débutera le 21 mai prochain entre l'état
les régions et les partenaires sociaux
pour assurer la mise en oeuvre effective
du compte personnel de formation
je pense également à toutes les
négociations de branche prévues par le
texte ou encore aux négociations au sein
des entreprises qui souhaitent
développer la mobilité interne ou mettre
en place des accords de maintien de
l'emploi
autrement dit le dialogue social
apparaît bien comme l'alpha et l'oméga
du projet de loi
sans renier je le redis nos prérogatives
de législateur en définitive je crois
pouvoir affirmer que la voix du
parlement malgré quelques des quelques
années a observé au cours de la navette
a réussi à être entendu sur ce projet de
loi qui marquera j'emmenais la
conviction le quinquennat aussi bien par
la méthode de travail retenu que par
l'ampleur des réformes proposées
indispensable pour gagner la bataille
pour l'emploi
je vous invite donc vous l'aurez compris
mes chers collègues a adopté les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est à monsieur
michel sapin ministre du travail de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social
mais son président monsieur le
rapporteur madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
je suis de nouveau devant vous au terme
d'un processus long riesch qui permettra
de donner corps à la sécurisation de
l'emploi si près d'aboutir je veux faire
retour sur ces quelques mois de débats
et de négociations pour en mesurer avec
vous le chemin parcouru
nous n'étions pas nombreux à croire que
nous pourrions aboutir rapidement à ce
texte de progrès quand nous avons décidé
d'en appeler à une grande négociation
interprofessionnelle sur tous les sujets
du marché du travail
je dis bien tous les sujets du même
darche il travaille en même temps lutter
contre la précarité sur le marché du
travail progressé dans l'anticipation
des évolutions de l'activité et des
compétences améliorer les dispositifs de
maintien de l'emploi face aux aléas la
conjoncture pour tourner le dos à cette
préférence pro française pour le
licenciement améliorer les procédures de
licenciement collectif
lorsqu'ils n'ont pu être évité par les
actions d'anticipation ou d'activité
partielle pour concilier un meilleur
accompagnement des salariés et une plus
grande sécurité juridique pour les
entreprises comme pour les salariés
tous ces sujets en même temps donc à la
recherche d'un équilibre global et on ne
traitant pas ce qu'ils facile et en
laissant de côté les sujets compliqués
au terme du parcours
un constat s'impose ce texte sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi est me
semble-t-il le plus ambitieux sur ces
questions de marché du travail depuis
1968 et nous avons conjurer l'échec de
la négociation interprofessionnelle de
1984 oui notre pays à trouver
le progrès par le dialogue social
nous n'étions peut-être pas si nombreux
à être convaincus qu'un équilibre serait
trouvé dans cette négociation sociale
qui a connu des tensions des
renversements de situation des séances
la journée et des impasses rappelez vous
c'était à noël dernier
le délai imparti la négociation était
écoulée les options des négociateurs
paraissait encore éloignés nous avons
choisi de donner quinze jours de plus à
la négociation et les partenaires
sociaux sont finalement parvenus à un
accord le soir du 11 janvier nous étions
déjà plus nombreux mais pas unanimes à
penser que de cet accord pourrait sortir
une loi sans ambiguïté nous avons réussi
dans un dialogue plus que constant quasi
permanent avec les partenaires sociaux à
traduire l'accord dans le droit dans la
loyauté vis-à-vis des signataires de cet
accord et dans l' écoute des non
signataires qui ont continué à être
associé au processus dans ces moments de
contact permanent je me suis dit que le
dialogue social à la française était en
train de s'affirmer comme une méthode de
sortir des discours pour entrer dans les
faits dans une pratique concrète et
spécifiques
nous étions nombreux à savoir que le
projet de loi passerelle parlement sans
que sont délicates équilibre ne soient
des à la thur et je reconnais bien
volontiers que les parlementaires à
l'assemblée nationale comme au sénat ont
dû composer avec ce projet de loi issu
du texte des acteurs eux-mêmes dans
lequel chaque mot était pesé était
équilibré mais nous avons montré vous
avez montré que la démocratie politique
savait accueillir en son sein la
démocratie sociale lui faire une place
et la respecter
cependant jamais le parlement n'a cédé
sa prééminence jamais la démocratie
politique n'a été supplanté le travail
en commission puis en séance a permis à
l'assemblée nationale comme au sénat
une étude de chaque point et des
améliorations dans le respect de la
fidélité à l'accueil à ce qu'ils ont dit
que le parlement ne serait qu'une
chambre d'enregistrement
vous avez répondu ici aussi c'est faux
et vous l'avez prouvé sur la
généralisation de la complémentaire
santé et sur le lien avec les contrats
responsables et solidaires amélioration
parlementaire sur le contenu et la
méthode de mise en oeuvre du compte
personnel de formation amélioration
parlementaire sur l'intégration
d'informations de nature
environnementale au sein de la base de
données économiques et sociales ainsi
que la mention des contrats précaires
stages et emplois à temps partiel
amélioration parlementaire sur les
droits et la protection des
représentants des salariés dans les
conseils d'administration amélioration
parlementaire sur le régime des coupures
au sein de la journée de travail dans le
cadre du temps partiel amélioration
parlementaire sur les accords de
mobilité interne et la protection de la
vie personnelle et familiale des
salariés notamment des mesures de
limites géographiques et
d'accompagnement
là encore amélioration parlementaire sur
les efforts demandés aux dirigeants et
aux actionnaires en cas d'accord de
maintien de l'emploi avec la notion de
proportionnalité
une fois encore une amélioration
parlementaire sur la procédure de
validation par l'administration des
accords valant pse et sur la suspension
du délai de prescription postérieurement
au licenciement
là encore amélioration parlementaire le
parlement a donc joué pleinement son
rôle de garant de l'intérêt général mais
surtout il a fait de l'accord la loi de
tous allant parfois jusqu'à convaincre
apaisé ou satisfaire des opposants
initiaux je tiens à remercier tout
particulièrement le rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales claude
jeannin pour son travail la qualité
l'élégance avec lequel il a assumé cette
responsabilité
je remercie aussi gaëtan gorce
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des lois pour le minutieux travail qui a
porté ses fruits avec des améliorations
parlementaire en commission et en séance
qui a permis notamment sur l'article 5
des améliorations substantielles
je veux également remercier catherine
génisson rapporteur pour la délégation
aux droits des femmes qui a notamment
examiné l'article 8 sur le temps partiel
puisque celui ci touche plus de 3
millions presque 4 millions de
françaises et naturellement je voudrais
aussi remercier annie david la
présidente de la commission pour avoir
piloté sans jamais renier ses
convictions et en les exprimant toujours
avec force les travaux de la commission
il y eut des moments difficiles dans le
processus mais nous n'avons ensemble
jamais lâché l'objectif de sécuriser
l'emploi de conforter le dialogue social
et de respecter les équilibres auxquels
acteurs économiques et sociaux étaient
eux mêmes par vous dit la loi en est
aujourd'hui plus forte
je sais que la sécurisation de l'emploi
n'évitera pas tous les licenciements
mais j'ai la conviction après vous
monsieur le rapporteur qu'elle offrira
des alternatives à beaucoup d'entre eux
la majorité des organisations syndicales
ont la même certitude
faisons donc confiance aux acteurs tous
les acteurs signataires ou non
signataires de cet accord national
interprofessionnel supporter ou
opposants de cette loi je suis convaincu
que tous seront s'en saisir
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
j'ai la conviction que ce texte
deviendra dans les mois les années qui
viennent
quoi que l'on en dise et on en pense
aujourd'hui un texte
d'apaisement et d'équilibré les
syndicalistes vont s'en saisir utiliser
les possibilités nouvelles pour négocier
des avancées pour les salariés pour
éviter des licenciements pour peser dans
la stratégie de l'entreprise
je le dis ce texte est un acte de
confiance est d'abord de confiance dans
les syndicats
si on a gagné dans une culture de
négociations parfois dures parfois
disputé plutôt que dans une culture de
conflit sans dialogue donc au fond
plus personne ne veut trop souvent notre
pays a douté de ses syndicats
représentants des salariés
certains disaient trop conservateur
troppo l'élite et une trop minoritaires
disaient d'autres
ce texte remet les salariés et leurs
représentants en position centrale celle
de faire advenir le progrès celle de
pouvoir agir passer des compromis dans
un cadre garantie ce texte leur dit vous
êtes légitime et c'est à vous de
construire un devenir meilleur pour et
avec les salariés vous avez maintenant
des instruments et des pouvoirs de
négocier qui le permettent
c'est toi mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs apporte cet
équilibre apporte ses opportunités
répond aux exigences de l'heure est aux
attentes pour demain vous y avez
largement contribué et de cela surtout
c'est bon je veux aussi vous remercier
merci monsieur le ministre dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à monsieur jean-noël cardoux pour le
groupe ump
mais monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'ai écouté avec attention les
propos des précédents intervenants et
vous comprendrez monsieur le ministre
que je ne partage pas le satisfecit que
vous nous avez décrit alors j'ai
illustrer mon propos des gens parlant
des problèmes de forme et ensuite en
m'attaquant ou font déjà sur la forme je
résumerais la situation avec 40 heures
de débat au sénat je crois que c'était
160 heure où l assemblée nationale une
commission mixte paritaire de trois
heures ce qui fait un total presque 100
heures de débats et tout ça pour aboutir
à ce que je qualifierais en pesant mes
mots d'une sorte de fiasco dans la
procédure utilisée par le gouvernement
fiasco pourquoi tu vois trois raisons la
première c'est que vous nous avez répété
à l'envi que le texte de l'ani était
parfaitement respecté et que vous aviez
coller à la nuit alors qu'une simple
lecture des deux textes prouve le
contraire c'est une lecture matériel
qu'en fait la retranscription avait des
voitures et certains éléments la
deuxième raison de ce fiasco
c'est que malgré la main tendue de le
groupe ump avait proposé au gouvernement
puisque nous étions dans une démarche
positive
eh bien vous êtes resté campé sur vos
positions et n'avait pas voulu varier
d'un iota troisième élément que je
soulignerai c'est l'incapacité que vous
avez eu de maîtriser l'opposition
frontale de la gauche de la gauche on a
vécu pendant des bas des séances assez
tendue et cette opposition non maîtrisée
et bien on l'a vu se traduire dans la
rue il ya pas si longtemps par des
manifestations du 5 mai alors devant un
gouvernement empêtré dans ses
contradictions
eh bien quelle a été la solution
préconisée par le ministre est bien ses
buts
disait une réaction que je qualifierais
d'autoritaire en imposant ce fameux
votre bloc est prévue à l'article 44
alinéa 3 de la constitution
c'est quand même une procédure rarissime
au sénat moi je suis un jeune sénateur
mais les anciens m'ont expliqué que ça
ne se pratiquait pas d'une manière
habituelle
et pourtant et pourtant on recherchons
un peu et en montant à trois ans suffit
de voir que membre éminent du parti
socialisme nam aubry en 2010 l'occasion
du débat sur les retraites avait fustigé
le gouvernement de l'époque en
l'accusant de pratiquer un coup de force
permanent et en précisant ce
contournement du parlement était
scandaleux en privant les élus de la
nation d'un débat légitime
comme quoi la vérité n'est pas toujours
la même suivant qu'elle est droite ou de
gauche
ce que je souhaite simplement monsieur
le ministre c'est qu'on nous avons
abordés dans cet hémicycle là aussi
votre proposition sur les retraites que
vous ne soyez pas contre a une nouvelle
fois d'utiliser ce vote bloqué alors
toujours sur la forme et bien le
résultat pour nous membres de l'ump
et quand même une frustration parce que
nous avions voulu nous avions voulu
présenter des amendements constructif je
rappelle simplement qu'au total nous
avions prévu moins de vingt amendement
parfaitement ciblée est justifiée alors
que le groupe crc en avait proposé 500
donc excusez-moi de la différence est
que cette approche que nous avions nous
au sein de notre groupe mettait en
évidence une opposition de méthodes tout
à fait significatives nous notre méthode
c'était une méthode de opposition
constructive avec des modifications qui
nous semblait fondé face à une
opposition que je qualifierais
d'instructives une opposition
d'obstruction qui était pratiqué par vos
alliés et donc ce qui s'est passé c'est
que vous avez choisi ce passage en force
est là
je vous entends des tout à leur dire
monsieur le ministre que chaque point du
texte a été étudié avec beaucoup
d'attention et de détails
désolé j'étais malheureusement pas là
cette nuit là mais quand j'ai appris que
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche on
était partis au vote bloqué et j'y
reviendrai dans mon propos nous n'avons
pas pu des formes certains de nos
amendements qui était parfaitement
justifiée c'est parce que j'appelle
avoir étudié tous les éléments du texte
point par point la fière quand même une
grosse une brosse forte une grosse
divergence d'interprétation et comme le
dit mon cher collègue charles revêt et
bien et pour terminer sur les questions
de forme de ce débat la démocratie
parlementaire n'en sortira pas grandie
alors maintenant c'est la traque est je
vais attaquer le fonds le fonds qui est
quand même le plus important puisque et
je le répète la démarche du groupe ump
n'a pas été de faire une révolution et
s'opposer systématiquement la démarche
de coupet était de s'approcher des
partenaires sociaux de lire la nuit et
de vouloir retransmise et d'une manière
beaucoup plus rigoureuses ce qui était
écrit dans la nuit c'était simple et
c'était vraiment coller à l'esprit des
partenaires sociaux majoritaire qui
avait signé ce texte alors je reviendrai
sur les deux points de divergence aux
fondamentaux sans toutefois omettre de
signaler un des éléments essentiels pour
lequel nous n'avons pas pu non plus
présenté d'amendements c'est quand même
la transformation par rapport au texte
de l'ani de la nature du licenciement
quand un salarié refuse la clause de
mobilité ou la procédure de maintien
dans l'emploi
l'ani prévoyant licenciements
individuels vous l'avez transformer en
licenciement économique individuel ce
qui est une encoche notion un petit peu
difficile à déterminer mais qui en
néanmoins ouvre la porte ouvre la porte
à des possibilités de judiciarisation
importante et c'est ce que tous
redoutent les entreprises quand une
entreprise à négocier pas facilement et
c'est normal les partenaires sociaux
veulent défendre chacun leur position
quand une entreprise a négocié
difficilement un accord
voir le risque trois ans après ou quatre
ans après par une décision judiciaire
on lui dise non c'était pas ça il faut
réintégrer du personnel et/ou faire
verser des indemnités beaucoup plus
importante
ce n'est pas ça qui assure à la
flexibilité et la sécurité du travail
dans les entreprises
donc je voulais signaler parce que ça
c'est quelque chose qui a moins été
développée que le reste dans le texte
mais qui risque à terme de déclencher
des conflits qu'ils seront extrêmement
dur à résoudre alors les deux les deux
éléments principaux
on a dit la clause désignation on y
revient alors des trois arguments que
nous avons retenu que vous ne savez pas
retenu vous monsieur le ministre
et je le répète le texte de la nuit
disait recommande recommandations et non
pas désignation deuxième chose
alors bien sûr vous avez dit que c'est
fort à propos que le conseil de la
concurrence émis un avis c'est en sorte
à propos c'est parce que une
organisation d'assurance a saisi parce
que justement elle était inquiète de la
tournure des événements et donc le
conseil de la concurrence a rendu son
avis bien sûr mitigé qui ne dit pas que
la cause de désignation est interdite
qui dit qu'elle existe mais qui
néanmoins qui néanmoins amis et émis de
telles réserves que on vous a vu dans
l'action gouvernementale dans des cas
différents avec une haute autorité une
énième haute autorité qui donnait un
avis controversés quand ça vous arrange
est hélas vous alliez tout à fait dans
le sens de la vie qui vous avait été
donné c'est dommage quand même que vous
n'ayez pas suivi l'avis du conseil de la
concurrence et puis la mutualisation
dire que cette mutualisation va
permettre des économies d'échelle bon
moi je pense que la meilleure
mutualisation et de meilleur gage de
prix de revient compétitif à l'égard de
partenaires sociaux et bien c'est tout
simplement la libre concurrence et en
imposant à des entreprises de souscrire
des contrôles mutuels avec des
organismes prêts désigné
par des accords de branche et bien nous
nous éloignons de la libre concurrence
on va ouvrir des conflits d'intérêts on
sait très bien
les statistiques ne donnent même si ce
chiffre est peut-être un peu élevé que
90% de montant de ses cotisations à
partir vers des organismes de prévoyance
au détriment des mutuelles et des
sociétés d'assurances d'ailleurs on les
voit actuellement pour certains
manifester devant le sénat
ils sont pas si loin d'ici et je pense
que cette entorse à la concurrence est
un motif non négligeable de saisine du
conseil constitutionnel
l'avenir nous le dira et puis je
rappelle simplement aussi et que et je
le souligne c'est une manne de trois
milliards et demi de cotisations
sociales plus 2 milliards de pertes
le manque à gagner fiscal pour le
gouvernement 5 milliards et demi qui
vont être distribués sans une mise en
concurrence réelle et légitime
c'est quand même un petit peu inquiet
temps et il faut bien constater aussi
que même si on peut contester les
chiffres que les organismes d'assurances
et de mutuelles part d'une perte sèche
de 40000 emplois en l'occurrence à
l'heure l'amendement que nous avions
présenté et qui avait été voté par la
majorité du sénat
nous avions de grands espoirs et bien
été sèchement repoussé en commission
mixte paritaire et j'avoue que les
arguments qui nous ont été opposés à
cette occasion là ne nous ont pas
réellement convaincu
deuxième point l'article 8 l'article 8
services à la personne alors là nous
avons été à l'écouté des utilisateurs et
de la population les services à la
personne des services médico sociaux les
services hospitaliers des portages de
journaux et tous ces petits boulots qui
sont peut-être
bien sûr pas facile a exercé par ceux
qui en bénéficient mais qui en moins
néanmoins à porte dans certaines zones
des compléments de revenus dans des
gliomes et vient nous voulions
simplement que ces éléments là une
dérogation soit ouverte pour permettre
d'adapter les situations locales et les
situations catégorielles aux taxes et
nous étions tout à fait du verrou
monsieur le ministre puisque nous
prévoyons simplement dans le texte de
déroger par décret et par décret c'est
le gouvernement que rue là bas pour
négocier ces dérogations à l'heure là
aussi je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui aurait pu se se discutent et se
négocier pour aveugles aboutir à un
consensus
alors j'ajouterai que sur ces deux
points nous sommes réalistes et
pragmatiques et j'ajouterais aussi que
certains membres de votre majorité
l'état j'ai assisté aux débats en
commission a entendu certaines voix
s'élever j'ai assisté aux débats à la
commission mixte paritaire où j'ai
entendu certaines voix s'élever nous
avons eu l'exemple que si notre fameux
nous amendement supprimant la clause de
désignation a été adopté c'est bien
parce qu'il y avait un petit peu de
flottement dans votre majorité et je
reprendrai un argument qui vient sortir
que un éminent membre du parti
socialiste président de la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale
monsieur jean jacques urvoas a dit qu'il
était lui opposé à titre personnel à la
clause de désignation alors je crois que
là le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il ya un léger flottement dans la
façon de vous aborder le problème est
que si vous voulez une preuve de ce que
vous auriez pu obtenir
l'article a demandé par nos soins avec
la majorité du sénat et la suppression
de la clause de désignation a quand même
été adopté par 311
contre 20 je pense qu'une telle majorité
au sénat
on ne la trouve pas si facilement et je
vous dis simplement imaginer un seul
instant monsieur le ministre si avec un
petit peu de diplomatie avec un petit
peu d'ouverture d'esprit vous aviez
permis à nos amendements d'être adopté
et bien qu'elle ait fait se ruent sur
l'ensemble de la population que la
majorité et l'opposition au sénat
s'entendent sur un test majeur sur un
texte majeur
je crois que là vous avez perdu et je le
crains pour vous une forte une forte
occasion de donner un signe à la nation
et malheureusement ce vote bloqué à tout
musée alors je poserai la question est
est ce bien le moment de rentrer dans
une telle logique d'affrontement au
moment où le pays dans une situation
économique absolument dramatique
il reviendra peut-être au moment où j'ai
lu dans des déclarations de certains
membres de votre majorité que ce cet
accord sur la flexisécurité était le
dernier élément de la boîte à outils du
président de la république mais ce que
je constate simplement c'est qu'à chaque
fois que vous ouvrez cette boîte à
outils
vous vous trompez de numéros de clé et
c'est pas comme ça qu'on avancera alors
je le dis et je le répète vous avez
perdu une sorte occasion de donner un
signe fort au pays et devant le
réquisitoire que je viens de deux
formules et beaucoup d'entre nous
attendent que je disais bien nous allons
nous opposer ce texte nous allons nous
opposer à ce texte parce que la main que
nous avons entendu n'a pas été saisie et
ce serait certainement logique et
certains d'entre nous le ferons
peut-être mais ce que je voudrais
simplement dire c'est que dans une telle
situation où ce texte on l'a bien connu
et est fondamental pour l'amélioration
de la flexibilité du travail un certain
moment il faut se montrer
il faut savoir dépasser l'entêtement
stérile et faire preuve d'un peu plus de
hauteur de vue et de privilégier devant
une situation économique dégradée et
bien privilégier l'intérêt supérieur du
pays
surtout que ce texte beaucoup d'acteurs
de la vie économique qu'ils soient
salariés ou entrepreneurs l'attendent
avec impatience
alors je ne pense que notre position
notre position groupe fera
majoritairement une abstention
majoritairement une abstention et pour
conclure je dirais que cette abstention
à deux facettes une abstention positive
positif parce que c'est la traduction
d'une nouvelle forme de dialogue social
que notre collègue gérard larcher avait
su institué en janvier 2007 et qui est
maintenant certainement bien ancrée dans
l'esprit des partenaires sociaux pour
faire avancer les modifications
nécessaires du droit du travail
deuxième élément c'est aussi notre
attention sera positive parce que c'est
un hommage appuyé
nous souhaitons rendre aux partenaires
sociaux une courage de passer beaucoup
de temps et de signer cet accord
et puis aussi parce que j'ai dit j'ai
souligné que malgré ses déficiences
malgré votre surdité
c'est un texte qui est positif malgré
des tenir dénaturation dont il a fait
l'objet
alors bien sûr il ya le volet négative
de l'abstention et le vol à négative de
l'abstention et bien on en parle
beaucoup en ce moment puisque le monde
du football fait la première née
télévision et des journaux et bien
le côté négatif de notre attention sur
un formidable carton rouge au
gouvernement devant son inflexibilité et
sans et son manque d'ouverture et c'est
je le crains la preuve d'une fuite en
avant inquiétante
je pense pas que c'est ainsi que vous
arriverez à faire remonter la popularité
d'un président de la république à la
dérive mais c'est votre choix
il va falloir vous l'assumez devant la
nation quant à nous nous aurons la
fierté de dire que nous avons fait
abstraction de nos conflits et nos
oppositions politiques
devant l'intérêt supérieur du monde
économique
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur dominique watrin pour le groupe
crc
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je ne reviendrai pas sur
les conditions dans lesquelles notre
assemblée a été contrainte de débattre
ce projet de loi sinon pour souligner
tout de même une contradiction ce qui
n'hésitait pas à dire que la
transposition de l'accord internet
interprofessionnel du 11 janvier devait
se faire dans le respect des signataires
n'ont pas hésité à baisser le rôle du
sénat contester le droit constitutionnel
d'amendements et à réduire le débat à sa
plus simple expression dole drôle de
respect du travail parlementaire
même avant l'utilisation du 44 3 nous
avons noté chacun de nos amendements a
été écarté au prétexte pour reprendre la
formule récurrente du rapporteur qu'ils
étaient hors champ de l'ani avec ce
texte le gouvernement a donc réussi à
diviser les syndicats de salariés a
divisé la majorité sénatoriale
il s'est attiré les foudres du syndicat
de la magistrature et du syndicat des
avocats de france qui souligne des
manquements constitutionnel qui ne
manqueront pas d'entraîner la
condamnation de la france devant les
instances
européennes sans parler des millions de
salariés de citoyens qui est indépendant
indépendamment de leur appartenance
syndicale dénonce cet accord il était
d'ailleurs le 5 mai quelque 180 milles à
paris à vous exhortez monsieur le
ministre a changé de cap et à renouer
avec le changement promis au monde du
travail par le candidat à la présidence
de la république
une mobilisation qui a dû vous touchez
monsieur le ministre puisque
contrairement débat initial vous n'avez
plus parler aujourd'hui d'accords
historiques en lieu et place du
changement ce projet de loi acte la
transposition dans notre droit interne
de toutes les exigences portées depuis
des décennies par le medef
selon le syndicat patronal les salariés
de notre pays coûterait trop cher leurs
droits collectifs et notre protection
sociale jugé trop rigide rendre et nos
entreprises - productrice main
productive éternel refrain
à l'opposé du discours de châlons en
champagne françois hollande rappeler à
raison que les salariés français est
plus productif que leurs homologues
allemands et que le coût du travail
était identique le gouvernement cède une
nouvelle fois aux pressions du medef et
donne un bien mauvais signal au monde
des affaires les nombreux salariés qui
subissent des salaires de misère qui
peinent à survivre avec le smig
quand des cadres dirigeants poches des
salaires supérieure de 20 fois au leurre
apprécieront mais ce sont eux qui
devront pourtant avec cette loi servir
encore plus de variables d'ajustement
pourtant vous le savez tous ici les
actionnaires du cac 40 ont eux pris
toutes leurs dispositions pour
stabiliser leurs revenus financiers
malgré la crise c'est sans doute pour
cela que vous avez permis à l'article 12
ce projet de loi aux employeurs de
baisser la rémunération des salariés en
cas de difficultés conjoncturelles c'est
à dire sous chantage à l'emploi une
baisse sans limite à la condition que le
salaire ne soit pas inférieure à 1,2
et ceux qui refuseront ce déclassement
seront licenciés à titre individuel pour
motif économique alors que pour la
première fois le pouvoir d'achat baisse
que la france est officiellement entrée
en récession vous permettez aux patrons
de compresser encore plus les salaires
quand l'urgence était au contraire de
les sécuriser
aucun discours ne justifie cette mesure
et je le dis mes chers collègues vous
aurez bien du mal dans vos
circonscriptions a expliqué que cette
mesure est positive et qu'elle constitue
un outil de sécurisation des parcours
professionnels
certes vous avez prévu pour donner
l'illusion que les salariés ne seraient
pas les seuls à être mis à contribution
que les dirigeants et les actionnaires
le serait aussi
mais ce soi-disant parallélisme est un
leurre tout d'abord cette contribution
sera prévu je cite dans le respect des
compétences des organes d'administration
et de surveillance comme si les
actionnaires allait se faire hara kiri
mais surtout on ne peut pas comparer les
deux situations d'un côté des
actionnaires qui détiennent plusieurs
actions dans leur portefeuilles qui
perçoivent des dividendes de plusieurs
entreprises qui pour les cadres
dirigeants cumuls parfois dividendes
actions gratuites stocks options jetons
de présence rémunération et de l'autre
des travailleurs qui n'ont que leur
salaire pour vivre de la même manière à
l'opposé de la promesse formulée par le
candidat hollande de rendre plus coûteux
les licenciements boursiers
vous réduisez le coût de tous les
licenciements en favorisant la
réparation forfaitaire que les
employeurs revendique depuis des années
au détriment de la réparation intégrale
des préjudices les procédures de
licenciements collectifs seront même
simplifiée là encore dans le seul
intérêt des employeurs qui n'auront plus
à prouver la réalité économique des
licenciements
pourtant ce sont elles qui génère le
plus de contentieux et par voie de
conséquence entraîne les indemnisations
les plus importantes là encore obéissant
aux injonctions du medef vous avez
sécurisé et non pas l'emploi
le licenciement de telle sorte que
demain les salariés ne pourront plus
contestées collectivement la réalité
économique du licenciement
comment pourraient-ils le faire
d'ailleurs quand l'autorité
administrative chargée d'homologuer la
procédure se limitera elle même à de
simples contrôles des contrôles de
mayran particulièrement limitées quand
on connaît la situation des effectifs
des directs et les délais dérisoire
prévu dans ce projet de loi de plus
alors qu'en l'état actuel du droit
national et international et
licenciements individuels pour motif
économique à partir de 10 salariés sont
requalifiées en licenciements collectifs
un employeur pourra licencier en france
sans limite pour le même motif
prétendument économique et dans le même
mois sans que jamais ces licenciements
ne soient qualifiés d' économique
un bien joli cadeau en vérité au
patronat qui sera ainsi dispensés des
efforts particuliers en matière de
reclassement de formation ou de priorité
de réembauche enfin ce texte permettra
lors d'une procédure de contestation
d'un plan de licenciement collectif que
le silence gardé par une juridiction
entraîne la transmission automatique à
la juridiction supérieure c'est ni plus
ni moins qu organiser un déni de justice
vous pourrez ainsi privé les salariés du
droit dont disposent tous les autres
justiciables a bénéficié d'un jugement
par un double degré de juridiction
de fait au bout de cette procédure
parlementaire qui a amené bien peu de
changement les salariés se verront
reconnaître moins de droits que les
autres créanciers des patrons alors que
les banquiers pourront par exemple
pendant cinq ans demander réparation les
salariés eux n'auront plus que trois ans
comme si les droits de la finance devait
primer sur ceux des travailleurs cette
situation a même ému le rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des lois qui bien
qu hostiles à cette mesure comme
l'ensemble de la commission n'a pas
déposé d'amendement
une inaction que l'on comprend mal à
l'ecoute de l'intervention générale
prononcée en première lecture si ce
n'est par la volonté de ne
embarrassé le gouvernement nous avons
d'ailleurs la même incompréhension à
l'égard de notre collègue catherine
génisson qui en qualité de rapporteur
pour avis au nom de la délégation aux
droits des femmes reconnaît
explicitement dans son rapport quand
l'état l'article 8 relatif au temps
partiel constitue une discrimination
indirecte mais elle ne s'y oppose pas et
ne propose aucune rédaction alternative
c'est donc un texte anticonstitutionnel
que vous a prêté mes chers collègues
adopté comme pour le bonus malus en
matière d'énergie vous ne pourrez pas
dire que vous n'avez pas été prévenus
nous en tirons pour notre part toutes
les conclusions et voteront contre ce
projet de loi
merci monsieur watrin la parole est à
monsieur jean marie van dalen baer pour
le groupe u10 uc
sur le président sud- ministre mes chers
collègues arrivés au terme de l'examen
de ce projet de loi portant sécurisation
de l'emploi je reviendrai pas longuement
sur les conditions de son examen qui ne
doivent d'ailleurs pas altéré
l'excellent travail de ses rapporteurs
et particulièrement de jean-claude
jeunes
en effet la première lecture du sénat
était littéralement putté parle usage du
44 3 on vient de le rappeler
nous regrettons vivement cette
conséquences extrêmes issue d'un conflit
qui ne nous concernent pas directement
un confit de la majorité sénatoriale
entre la gauche de la gauche et le reste
de votre fragile associations nous le
regrettons d'autant plus qu'il s'agit
d'un texte important essentiel
il transpose un accord national
professionnel interprofessionnelle pardo
qui marque un dépassement de
l'antagonisme traditionnel des
partenaires sociaux en france et un
changement dans la conduite du dialogue
social dans notre pays un accord
gagnant-gagnant avez vous dit pour les
employeurs et les salariés et nous
l'espérons pour l'emploi l'accord
national du 11 janvier dernier
concrétise en effet la préoccupation que
des centristes ont toujours affirmé et
qui est aujourd'hui largement partagé
sur les bandes cet hémicycle de faire
confiance en la démocratie sociale et de
la voir s'affirmer
ce qui était le sens d'ailleurs de la
loi larcher du 31 janvier 2016 qui à
2007 pardon qui impose que tous très
fort touchant au droit social fasse
l'objet d'une concertation préalable
mais s'il a ni doit être saluée c'est
bien sûr aussi et surtout pour son
contenu il met en place ce que nous
appelons nos voeux depuis de nombreuses
années une flexisécurité à la française
des droits nouveaux pour les employeurs
et les salariés afin de favoriser le
maintien dans l'emploi est sécurisé le
licenciement et la mobilité à terre
notre position
mission vis-à-vis de ce texte vous la
connaissez monsieur le ministre
elle découle de ce constat puisque dans
notre système de hiérarchie des normes
il nous faut transposer l'accord pour
lui donner force de loi
alors il faut le faire sans le centre
dénaturer le texte de la cmp dénature
t-il l'ani la question est là nous
pensons que non sauf sur un point et
nous nous en avons nous en avons déjà
beaucoup parler bien sûr c'est celui de
la clause de désignation de l'opérateur
de la complémentaire santé au sénat nous
étions parvenus à dépasser les
sensibilités partisanes pour revenir au
texte initial de lagny et supprimer
cette clause la cmp n'a pas gardé cette
rédac cette rédaction et nous le
regrettons
sur le fond il ya visiblement un confie
sur ce thème au sein des bronzes
patronale plus précisément d'ailleurs
entre la fédération française des
sociétés d'assurances nous là et les
autres secteurs
quant aux syndicats de salariés le texte
leur convient apparemment très bien
et pour cause je ne m'étendrai pas
là-dessus j'ai bien entendu vos
explications aussi monsieur le ministre
sur l'ouverture des trois perspectives
offertes ou aux branches désignation
recommandations ou liberté totale du
président du choix du prestataire
mais je rappelle quand même qu'un accord
de branche en portant désignation unique
contre les employeurs à se soumettre
sans sauf sauf à remettre en cause la
gouvernance de leur range donc les
conflits ne manqueront pas de naître
entre les partisans de la mutualisation
et les autres quoi qu'on fasse
mais ce n'est pas notre affaire
avez-vous dit alors en conclusion sur ce
sujet ne seront pas plus royalistes que
le roi ou ministre que parlementaire et
nous laisserons les partenaires sociaux
et les branches patronale régler leurs
problèmes en famille espérons simplement
que cette clause ne deviendra pas un nid
à caen
monsieur au regard de l'avis de la haute
autorité de la concurrence
revenons à l'essentiel c'est-à-dire à
l'instauration à l'article 1 de la
complémentaire santé pour tous les
salariés
nous nous félicitons que la cmp mc trois
amendements visant à prendre en compte
d'une part maintenu nos amendements
pardon pas 3 nos amendements visant à
prendre en compte d'une part le
caractère collectif de l'adhésion à
contrats d'assurance découlant d'une
obligation formulée par un accord de
branche ou professionnels et surtout
d'autre part les situations d'employeurs
multiples et des salariés à temps
partiel ce dernier point nous tenait
particulièrement à coeur parce qu'ils
concernent très spécifiquement le
secteur des services aux particuliers ce
qui me conduit au second point de
cristallisation des débats celui relatif
à l'article 8 cet article qui crée un
socle de garanties minimales destinées à
encadrer l'usagé du temps partiel cela
nous ne pouvons que le saluer bien
entendu mais le cadre doit être adaptée
à certaines activités singulièrement
celle de la branche sanitaire social et
médico-social et celle aussi des
services à la personne ou même du
portage de presse malheureusement le
vote bloqué à empêcher nous a empêchés
d'adopter toute adaptation du texte à
ces cas particuliers au sénat et la cmp
n'a pas modifié non plus ce texte nous
gang et ont même si nous avons bien
entendu vos explications monsieur le
ministre vous avez largement ouvert le
champ de la négociation ce qui est une
bonne chose et même une nécessité et
nous vous en remercions
mais le problème c'est que si le secteur
médico-social est représentée par des
syndicats professionnels les
associations et les professionnels du
secteur des services à la personne ne
dispose pas d'une représentation très
organisé comment donc allez vous vous y
prendre pour éventuellement adapter le
cadre de l'article 8 à leur situation
ce ministre nous serons très attentifs à
cette question et surtout à votre
réponse
pour le reste nous sommes en phase avec
le texte issu des travaux de la cmp qui
n'a que peu modifié faut le dire celui
du sénat c'est le cas sur les articles
les plus importants
je pense à l'article 5 il y assure une
représentation des salariés au conseil
d'administration de surveillance s'agit
là d'une mesure importante de
gouvernance des entreprises qui
correspond à notre philosophie la
démocratie sociale le sénat avait
amélioré le texte en faisant de la
représentativité la représentation
pardon inscrite dans le texte à plancher
la cmp a conservé cette rédaction et
même apporté deux modifications qui vont
dans le bon sens me semble-t-il
permettant aux entreprises qui le
souhaitent d'accorder davantage de temps
de formation à la salarié nouvellement
élus ou désignés et d'accélérer leur
entrée en fonction
enfin à l'article 12 relatif à l'accord
de maintien de l'emploi qui n'a pas été
d'ailleurs substantiellement modifié par
la cmp
nous ne pouvons que soutenir la seule
modification qui a été apportée elle
prévoit la possibilité d'ajouter les
indemnités contractuelles aux indemnités
conventionnelles et légales pour le
calcul des indemnités dont pourra
bénéficier à salariés en cas de refus
d'une modification de son contrat de
travail
nous soutenons cette modification
d'autant plus qu'elle peut apparaître
comme un complément de l'amendement que
nous avions fait adopté en première
lecture et qui a été conservé par la cmp
qui prévoit les mêmes dispositions en
cas de rupture du contrat de travail
consécutives à la suspension de l'accord
de maintien de l'emploi
nous soulignerons aussi pour terminer
l'importante avancée que représente la
cre en la création du compte personnel
formation et qui a été évidemment repris
par la cmp en revanche en revanche nous
regrettons la timidité mais ça ne dépend
pas de nous mais de l'accord national
interprofessionnel des efforts des
entreprises pour réduire les contrats
courts de travail avec l'espoir
néanmoins que ce ne soit qu'une première
étape
en conclusion vous l'aurez compris le
groupe u10
c'est un terreau pleinement à la
philosophie de l'ani considère que
globalement sa transposition législative
ne l'a pas dénaturer il le votera donc
dans sa grande majorité
merci de votre ascension merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à madame
françoise laborde pour le groupe rds
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues m selon les
derniers chiffres publiés il y a
quelques semaines la france compte
désormais plus de trois millions deux de
demandeurs d'emploi inscrits à pôle
emploi en catégorie à c'est à dire sans
aucune activité
cette hausse qui intervient pour le 23e
mois consécutif plonge l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens dans la crainte d'un avenir
incertain d'autant que la précarité
envahit peu à peu leur vie quotidienne
souvent assimilée à la grande pauvreté
elle atteint aujourd'hui une telle
ampleur qu'elle concerne tout un plan de
population qui va bien au delà des plus
défavorisés dans le contexte économique
particulièrement difficile que nous
connaissons depuis plusieurs années il
est nécessaire de se mobiliser pour
inverser la courbe du chômage à la fin
de l'année la bataille pour l'emploi est
une nécessité impérieuse
il faut reconnaître monsieur le ministre
depuis maintenant un an vous vous
atteler à ce dossier avec toute la
persévérance que nous vous connaissons
emplois d'avenir contrat de génération
et maintenant sécurisation de l'emploi
tous les leviers de votre politique de
l'emploi seront bientôt opérationnels
ces outils n'ont certes pas encore porté
leurs fruits et l'impatience des
français se fait grandissante
mais le président de la république l'a
récemment rappelé son quinquennat
comportera deux phases une phase de
redressement
pendant laquelle des réformes difficiles
mais indispensables seront conduites et
une phase de dépassement pour permettre
de changer de modèle et de vivre mieux
le projet de loi dont nous achevons
aujourd'hui l'examen fait partie
intégrante de cette phase de
redressement
faut-il rappeler qu'il est la
transcription d'un accord signé par
trois des cinq syndicats de salariés et
par tous les syndicats d'employeurs
accord que le chef de l'état lui-même
qualifié de compromis historique
bien que l'examen par le parlement ne se
soit pas fait sens
nous pouvons nous féliciter d'avoir
enrichi un texte qui pour la première
fois depuis bien des années
consacre le dialogue social non
seulement comme la seule voie efficace
pour porter des réformes justes et
nécessaires mais aussi comme la méthode
caractéristiques choisi par ce
gouvernement
et c'est tant mieux le premier ministre
s'est engagé à recevoir l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux pour faire le point
sur leurs attentes et recueillir leurs
propositions en vue de la deuxième
conférence sociale qui aura lieu en juin
prochain
les premiers échanges ont d'ailleurs
débuté hier pour sortir de la crise et
combattre le chômage
notre pré pays doit concilier
compétitivité des entreprises et
sécurisation des emplois
c'est à mon sens la clé de la
performance économique dont nous avons
plus que jamais besoin
le projet de loi donne aux entreprises
les outils pour une plus grande
réactivité aux évolutions
conjoncturelles dans une période où le
chômage de masse et la précarité ne
cesse d'augmenter
il est important que les entreprises
puissent adapter aux évolutions
économiques et les anticiper plutôt que
d'y répondre en catastrophe je pense
notamment à la mobilité interne au
chômage partiel aux accords de maintien
dans l'emploi
je sais que ces dispositions suscitent
beaucoup d'opposition elle constitue
pourtant un moyen d'éviter les
licenciements massifs
à l'image de ce qui s'est passé chez
volkswagen et le travail parlementaire a
permis de mieux encadrer ces dispositifs
dans l'intérêt des salariés
certes je comprends que certaines
mesures telles que la réduction des
délais de prescription
puis susciter quelques craintes il faut
toutefois se rappeler les raisons pour
lesquelles les syndicats ont signé
l'accord du 11 janvier ils ont consenti
car il s'agissait d'une contrepartie à
de nouveaux droits individuels ou
collectifs à ce corps des hauts salariés
j'en citerai quelques-uns
l'accès de tous les salariés à une
couverture complémentaire nécessaire
dans un pays où de plus en plus de
personnes il renonce par manque de
moyens la création du compte personnel
de formation l'encadrement du temps
partiel la mise en place de droits
rechargeables à l'assurance chômage ou
encore la taxation des contrats courts
toutes ces dispositions vont dans le
sens d'une meilleure protection des
salariés
à ce titre elles constituent des avances
heures des avancées majeures
personne ne peut le nier bien sûr je
regrette que la plupart de nos
amendements n'ait pas été adoptée par le
sénat en première lecture
alors qu'ils allaient dans le sens d'une
meilleure protection du salarié
en revanche je me félicite que la
commission mixte paritaire est maintenu
notre proposition de rétablir la
rédaction de l'assemblée nationale
s'agissant du nombre de représentants de
salariés dans les conseils
d'administration ainsi ce nom sur un
seuil plancher et non plus une
prescription impérative il s'agit là
d'un progrès pour la revalorisation des
salariés est une véritable rupture dans
la gouvernance des entreprises
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons cette
réforme est tout simplement ambitieuse
elle est la condition sinequanone pour
faire sortir le pays de la crise
économique
ramenée de l'emploi en france et
redonner à tous nos concitoyens espoir
et confiance en l'avenir
selon les propres termes des
organisations syndicales signataires il
s'agit d'une avancée sociale c'est
pourquoi vous l'aurez compris le groupe
du rds dans sa grande majorité vous
apportera son soutien et aucun de ses
membres ne votera contre l'adoption des
conclusions de la cmp
je vous remercie merci madame laborde la
parole est à monsieur jean desessard
pour le groupe écologie
ce président monsieur le ministre il
sera porteur madame la porter chers
collègues le projet de loi sécurisation
de l'emploi et la transcription
législative de l'ani l'accord national
interprofessionnel et après tous ces
débats j'ai cherché à le comprendre et
le mot qui vient à l'esprit c'est le nid
l'objet législatif non identifié
en effet il est difficile à définir
s la simple traduction législative de
l'année et où sont les textes
monsieur le ministre qui délègue aux
partenaires sociaux l'ensemble des
relations sociales du pays
qu'en est il de la prise en compte des
chômeurs des précaires des non salariés
des retraités
lorsqu'il est question de la
sécurisation de l'emploi
qui peut raisonnablement penser que cela
se limite à l'entreprise évidemment
l'état les collectivités locales la
chambre des acteurs de la société ont un
rôle à jouer
oui l'étude d'un texte élaboré par les
partenaires sociaux doit être débattu et
amendé par les parlementaires
or pendant tout le débat le ministre
nous a constamment rappelée à l'ordre
pour coller au plus près du texte de
l'ani quel est donc le vrai statut de ce
projet de loi le gouvernement at il
décidé de sous-traiter les relations
sociales aux partenaires sociaux et si
c'est le cas il convient de le clarifier
institutionnel le mans 2e point venons
en à l'aspect aux reflets chatoyants de
l'aulne nique
les couleurs sont attrayantes attractive
mais qu'en est il réellement
bien sûr nous nous réjouissons de
l'extension de la complémentaire santé
mais mais
n'est ce pas au prix d'un
affaiblissement du rôle de la sécurité
sociale et d'un possible développement
des mutuelles à l'américaine d'ailleurs
les clauses de désignation le préfigure
d'où la manifestation des abeilles
aujourd'hui devant le sénat qui
défendent une mutuelle de proximité bien
sûr nous sommes satisfaits des droits
rechargeables à l'assurance chômage mais
sans recettes supplémentaires de
l'assurance chômage comment la financer
on prend à l'heure à paul pour denain
pierre
quelle est la catégorie qui sera moins
déguisés pour financer ce nouveau droit
bien sûr nous soutenons la création d'un
compte personnel de formation
mais quelles en sont les modalités
pratiques ce droit sera t'il réellement
effectif
bien sûr nous nous réjouissons de la
possibilité de pouvoir tester un travail
dans une autre entreprise avec la
possibilité de réintégrer la première si
les choses se passent mal
mais cela est soumis à l'autorisation de
l'employeur qui peut refuser deux fois
et s'il n'a pas le droit de refuser la
troisième ce n'est pas pour l'autoriser
mais pour permettre aux salariés de suit
une formation bien sûr nous soutenons la
citation cd pour les jeunes de moins de
26 ans mais j'attends avec impatience le
bilan car les incitations financières
sont faibles et en plus cela crée un
précédent d'exonération à l'assurance
chômage
bien sûr nous soutenons la taxation des
emplois précaires
mais pourquoi n'avoir pas mené une
véritable réflexion sur le temps partiel
et la précarité
à titre d'exemple les 20000 employés
vacataires des instituts de sondages ne
peuvent bénéficier de la prime de
précarité de 10% mais seulement 2 4%
pourquoi me sers mes chers collègues
nous nous réjouissons de la constitution
d'une base de données économiques et
sociales mais pourquoi avoir refusé de
les larges
dire aux données environnementales avec
aujourd'hui l'importance de
l'environnement dans notre société
alors maintenant arrêtons nous sur le
noyau dur de ce texte
l'accord de maintien de l'emploi dans
les entreprises en difficulté
l'objet est affichée pour permettre la
survie de l'entreprise
il peut y avoir négociation du contrat
de travail en termes d'horaires de
salaire et ce jusqu'au redressement de
l'entreprise
mais les circonstances de son
application reste flou dans le cadre de
la concurrence
quel pape on ne sera pas tenté de
vouloir renégocier le contrat de travail
face à une conjoncture qui la présente
comme difficile ne serait ce pas le
toboggan qui entraîne l'ensemble du
salariat vers le bas les accords
nationaux les accords de branche
garantissent le progrès social
en fixant le cadre de la concurrence
entre les entreprises avec la
possibilité d'y déroger
chaque entreprise sera tentée de
succomber à l'appel du dumping social
pour rester compétitives bien sûr
c'était un accord tout est validé par
les syndicats de l'entreprise
mais quel est le syndicat qui prendra le
risque de s'y opposer avec les propos
alarmistes de tout l'encadrement pour
sauvegarder l'entreprise
et oui je ne parlerai pas de la
réduction des délais de prescription
pour parts et les conflits aux
prud'hommes elles s'inscrivent dans une
réduction des droits des salariés
de même que je ne parlerai pas des
dispositions sur la mobilité interne
mais vous voyez bien qu'il reste de
nombreuses questions non résolues et on
aurait pu penser qu'il fallait le temps
du débat pour clarifier il aurait fallu
prendre le temps d'y réfléchir
au lieu de cela monsieur le ministre
vous allez utiliser le vote bloqué au
bout de 48 48 heures de débats je vous
rappelle que la dernière fois que
procédure a été utilisé
ce feu au bout de trois semaines de
débat sur les retraites
et comme je les dis monsieur le ministre
ce texte difficilement identifiables sa
trajectoire
aujourd'hui est difficile à cerner
s'agit-il d'un droit nouveau
ou au contraire d'une régression des
droits des salariés
comme nous n'avons pas pu clarifier le
groupe écologiste se tiendra au merci
monsieur des essarts la parole est à
monsieur jean louis masson pour la
réunion des non-inscrits
monsieur munissent mme ce président ou
chers collègues
la france est confrontée à une crise
économique sans précédent et dans ce
cadre je considère que l'accord national
interprofessionnel est incontestablement
une avancée parce que pour la première
fois il y a une véritable rupture avec
les pratiques de certains syndicats qui
sont encore branché sur la lutte des
classes certains syndicats complètement
préhistorique qui n'ont strictement rien
à faire de la situation économique de la
france et qui cherche simplement à
perdurer dans le système ancien que l'on
a connu donc je me réjouis de ce qu'il y
ait des syndicats progressiste tourné
vers l'avenir
tourné vers l'amélioration vers
l'intérêt général vers l'intérêt de la
france et qui ont accepté de passer une
concertation une convention avec l'autre
partie prenante des discussions sociales
qui est le patronat est ce que j'aurais
souhaité c'est que cet accord soit
intégralement respectés malheureusement
il ya eu des petits aménagements
ceci étant c'est une grande date et je
crois qu'il est important que le
parlement vote
ce projet de loi car nous montreront
ainsi que la représentation nationale
soutient une évolution des rapports
sociaux
c'est uniquement si on arrive à
disloquer cet acte du rejet systématique
de l'obstruction et cetera que
finalement on arrivera à redresser la
france et donc pour ma part je voterai
ce projet de loi sans hésiter ceci étant
le groupe des non-inscrits est à la fois
démocratique et est très pluraliste et
mon collègue jean françois husson m'a
demandé de m'exprimer à sa place de vous
faire part de son point de vue à sa
place il se trouve que nous n'avons pas
tout à fait la même opinion sur le sujet
et donc je vais vous lire le texte qu'il
m'a demandé de formuler
pour parce que disons ne pouvait pas
être là pour s'exprimer alors monsieur
jean françois husson souhaite vous faire
savoir que le texte d'aujourd'hui aurait
dû marquer un tournant de la démocratie
sociale dans notre pays
l'objectif annoncé par le président de
la république était louable et même
partager renforcer la sécurité les
droits des salariés tout en apportant
aux entreprises une certaine souplesse
et des formes de flexibilité dont ils
ont tant besoin
l'accord national interprofessionnel du
11 janvier 2013 a été adopté dans un
climat tendu après des débats houleux
mais avec succès les partenaires sociaux
avait ainsi rempli leur part du contrat
il restait aux législateurs à transposer
fidèlement les dispositions législatives
qui s'imposait comme le président de la
république les invités malheureusement
le gouvernement et la majorité
parlementaire se sont éloignés des
objectifs qu'il s'était fixés plus
largement leur attitude ne respecte les
grands principes démocratiques ne
respecte pas les grands principes
démocratiques qu'ils prétendent pourtant
défendre tout d'abord la démocratie
sociale à laquelle nous sommes attachés
est mise à mal certaines dispositions
ont fait l'objet de modifications
sensibles remettant en cause le subtil
équilibre trouvé par les partenaires
sociaux
les prétendus amélioration accroît ses
obligations et réglementations imposées
aux entreprises et employeurs comme si
les représentants des salariés n'avaient
pas été en mesure de faire entendre leur
voix lors des négociations
ceux d'entre eux minoritaires qui ont
des noms si l'accord ont obtenu gain de
cause sur certains points en dépit du
compromis obtenu par la majorité
comprenne qui pourra ensuite en ayant
recours à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
constitution sur un texte aussi
fondamentale qui touchent l'ensemble de
la population active
le gouvernement fait peu de cas de la
valeur ajoutée du travail du sénat dont
chacun reconnaît le sérieux certains sur
les bandes notre assemblée ont vivement
regretté et dénoncé une attitude aussi
négligente méprisant le temps consacré à
l'élaboration d'amendements pour tout
dire le gouvernement avait manifestement
son idée serait transposition de
l'accord
elle n'était pas question d'en changer
enfin le gouvernement aurait souhaité
bousculer les règles du calendrier
parlementaire afin d'expédier l'adoption
du texte
heureusement le sénat a veillé à faire
respecter l'agenda prévu et je m'en
félicite
en voulant gagner du temps le
gouvernement s'est mis la chambre à eau
la chambre haute à dos et s'est retrouvé
au point mort si le projet de loi qui
nous est soumis aujourd'hui reprend en
grande partie d'accord certaines
dispositions inopportune ont été
introduites et elles seront très contre
très contre-productives
tout d'abord l'introduction à l'article
1er d'une clause de désignation des
organismes assureurs par les branches
professionnelles pour une autre porte
une atteinte grave aux principes de la
liberté oui je termine monsieur
président principe de la liberté
contractuelle
ensuite le crédit d'impôt et de
compétitivité pour l'emploi accordé aux
entreprises pour alléger leurs charges
fiscales se voit soumis au contrôle des
représentants salariés ensuite également
l'instauration de la durée minimale du
temps de travail de 24 heures par
semaine et trop strictement encadré il
résulte de ces débats un sentiment de
gâchis le gouvernement et la majorité
avaient l'occasion de rassembler les
parlementaires ou tel autour d'un texte
consensuel mais ce n'est pas le cas pour
ces raisons notre collègue jean françois
husson m'a demandé de faire savoir qu'il
ne votera pas le texte issu des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat mais
nous reviendrons plus largement dans
notre édition de 19h sur ce vote du
sénat sur la cmp sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi tout de suite sans plus tarder
ses preuves par 3 l'émission politique
de la rédaction de public sénat qui
reçoit ce soir najat vallaud belkacem
porte-parole du gouvernement et ministre
des droits des femmes bonne soirée à
tous
s'attaquer à moi c'était comme si que